[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
I was
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
your word O Lord is a lamp unto my feet
and a light unto my path let us pray
o mighty god and everlasting father who
was the fount of all wisdom the living
truth which founded the world our life
in our light it is you who have
preserved and sustained us to this day
you have given us hearts to desire you
strength to seek you and minds to know
you to you alone we owe all that we are
all that we know and all that we desire
all for which we hope all to which we
aspire every breath we breathe to you
alone the all glory laud and honor we
give you thanks for all that this day
represents lessons learned and exams
completed pages read and reports written
recitals played and art shows hung hard
work rewarded and procrastination
sometimes resisted semesters ended and
sleepless nights have indicated game
days won and tailgates celebrated mock
rocks danced and central hall Opelousas
performed conversations had and
arguments amended tears shed and
laughter shared hurts suffered and
shoulders cried on friends made and
memories treasured journeys begun and
journeys ended how can we possibly thank
you for these gifts and ten-thousands
besides as we conclude this season and
commence another we commend these
proceedings and ourselves into your care
go before us and go behind us go above
us and go beneath us walk beside us and
dwell within us protect us roundabout
and guide our steps by your good will
and loving kindness shown finally to our
race by your son Jesus Christ receive
this our offering of our souls and
bodies dedicated to your service and
your glory may it be a fragrant aroma
before you we come before your throne of
grace this day with boldness not on
account of our righteousness but because
you have inscribed upon us the name
which is above every name that of Jesus
Christ our Lord to him to you and to the
Holy Spirit the honor and glory now and
forever amen please remain standing
please join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance
please be seated
welcome to the hundred sixty-six
commencement exercises of Hillsdale
College thank you for coming this is our
largest crowd they've been getting
bigger and bigger anyway in this year we
tried to suppress the name of the
speaker but we were unsuccessful I
welcome vice president Pence and more
importantly his wife Karen who who will
soon have the honorary graduates of our
College
I think his staff the advance team and
the Secret Service who are efficient and
kind and I recognize among them
especially Stephen Ford and Ryan Murphy
who in recent years were hillsdale
college students and we never thought
they were gonna work out where are they
anyway
yeah you should go ask him how they ever
got in the place they're in my job is to
I'm Larry R and I'm the president of the
college and my job is to explain the
purpose of this ceremony because we all
have a part in it it's for all of us
it's something we've all produced it is
not ending it is commencing we are
beginning something each of us is
essential to what happens here today
none of it would have happened without
every group who is here and in the case
of the individual seniors without many
individuals who are here
the purpose of the college from its
first day is the protection of
perpetuation of civil and religious
freedom and intelligent PI D through
sound learning we are commencing to live
a good life and learning and faith added
to moral character are the essentials of
that good life we call it commenced
because these seniors have qualified
themselves to commence that
they won't master it ever and not even
nearly completely us they keep at it but
they have surely been at it here you
notice a lot of us are wearing robes I'm
gonna say word about that in a minute
but first I want to recognize to thank
those of you who don't have a road
you're out of uniform
you're civilians we often talk of you of
you that way around here as in one of my
favorite things to say when I see
students doing something I always say
behave yourself kids they're civilians
around most of you are civilians and you
fall into two groups I'm going to think
the most important civilians here first
how did these seniors come to be how did
they get here they have parents families
they have grown up to do this this is
not easy not easy even to get in here
very hard to complete it to complete it
with honor that's such a thing such an
achievement they struggle and they
strive to do it and you are the ones
who've helped them what have you done
since they came right what you've done
has you done the phone a Thon's the
prayer groups and you've referred people
to the college and you host events all
the time we have a lot of events at the
college and I just noticed there's
always several tens of thousands of
dollars of free Labor's stand it around
and they always have parent on their
sticker right here and why we have their
kid it's a common production they flock
to parents weekend I think the record
attendance is 980 parents at parents
weekend it's a what you're a marvel to
us and I know you're not as sad today as
you were the day you left him off here
four years ago because now it's kind of
done and you don't to pay for it anymore
and you're proud of what they've
achieved with the parents please stand
up
[Applause]
the rest of you not wearing a uniform
are friends of the seniors and of the
college you stand for millions of others
I don't know how many people watch the
stream of this but it'd be a lot they're
about 4 million people who are on the
mailing list of Hillsdale College they
help us in a million ways some of them
give us money but in other ways they
talk about us they help us meet people
they broadcast the message of high
learning that the complet is the
college's purpose and without that you
know I made a joke about the parents
paying for it and they do but you know
they don't pay for quite half of it
other people people who don't know these
seniors they pay for it why would they
do that they don't get anything back
come to think of it why would the
parents exhaust themselves when these
kids are 20 years old and 21 years old
to help them grow up right and they
don't get anything back either
the answer is love it is a large
community of love thank you friends all
of you wherever you are we welcome you
in the academic community we are led by
the faculty they have uniforms and they
have stripes on them to indicate their
rank
David the Provost is a graduate of the
University of Kansas and so he's wearing
the robe of the University of Kansas
that's his unit and he's wearing the
three stripes that go with the doctor of
philosophy Dean Smith is he up here
that's missing here okay past reader
know where he comes from he's wearing
the bright red robe of the Claremont
Graduate School where I happen to have
agreed from and and he's got his three
stripes too and that's his credential to
lead here in the way that he does I'm
wearing the robe of the college I have a
medallion College's medallion what I
came to work here it's my first job in a
college I didn't know any of that stuff
and they were fitting me for this row
but I didn't know what color it should
be anything I didn't need to know people
around here know that and I said wait
there are too many stripes and I have
four and the lady said you're the
president silly do you see what that
means in formal occasions
we are designated to do what we do and
of course it's never just Authority its
responsibility what do they do these
faculty members 30 years of learning at
the least
all of them any more than that now used
to being the brightest people they know
and what they do is they deepen their
knowledge of a thing never to get rich
it's a poor way to do that didn't it and
you know they'd like to make it a little
more but why why did they do that right
and then they take these and these are
18 to 21 years old it's an amazingly
conventional College if you see them and
they look kind of like grown-ups it
means they're seniors and if they look
kind of like freshman like little kids
it means they're freshmen and the
transition goes
between you I can walk on somebody
else's campus and recognize it now and
they you know they're drinking from a
firehose they're young and ignorant and
these people are learning and they talk
to them into the night in class and out
they stay up with them when they need it
they correct them when they're wrong
they counsel them when they're down they
inspire them they give them the most
precious thing the thing they've spent
their lives learning their that activity
is the activity of a college I asked the
faculty to stand up so we can thank them
[Applause]
anybody not his have his papers graded
yet but nobody it's an inside joke but
I'll make it outside I've never met any
human being however great a faculty
member who likes to grade papers but we
do it three have won distinctions this
year that I always mentioned this
ceremony we give the Dougherty Award for
teaching excellence to a junior mentor
both faculty in the fall and a senior
member in the spring and this year's
winners are dr. Courtney Myette of
chemistry and dr. Nathan Sleater of
philosophy and religion would they stand
up please
they are selected by a committee of the
faculty and it's a roll of Honor the
people who won that the senior class
conspires every year to pick a professor
of the year and this year it's Adam
Carrington of the politics department
would he stand up please
oh yeah
are you doing over there Adam oh you're
a marshal I see yeah yeah I was about to
revoke his award I thought he wasn't
here to our faculty members are retiring
after very long service George angel of
theater and speech has been here for 34
years he's been chairman of that
department for 22 years he's directed 55
productions here and the ones he lists
are an insight into his character Tommy
to tempest-tossed iron bird fusion to
mirror of the invisible world I never
heard of either of those two but he he
liked him
he's been the rock of the theatre and
speech Department for much longer than I
have been here and we are deeply
grateful to George angel please stand up
maybe George is not here is he already
going to see from the chemistry
department we have a biologist has been
here for 21 years
he's a interesting guy for a biologist
he's a quiet guy you might think that
but he's a sex offender he plays a mean
jazz saxophone I've heard him do it and
he restores cars and make some beautiful
old cars he knows everything about them
and in his efficient caring way he has
been a tireless friend to our students
for those 21 years and we think and ask
to stand up Bob Miller please
hey Brandon where's Jorge tell him shame
on him see they're retired now what do
they care you know I'm not as grateful
as I was a minute ago now the Provost
Weiland just noticed that this is the
last commencement of two people who
haven't put their name on the list
because they're very contrary people and
they are former Provost former acting
president of the college
Bob Blackstock and his wife Jackie and I
would like to ask them to stand up
there they're retiring in December when
few people retire probably because they
want to hog glory for themselves
actually Jackie's not like that
there's so many of you I wonder if you
can hear all this apparently I
congratulate the seniors they too are
wearing a uniform it designates their
rank they have some ribbons all of the
ribbons are granted by the college and
by groups that they join that are
recognized by the college and the
ribbons indicate some distinction or
another but the chief distinction is
their black road which is long if you go
to college and Oxford which I did for a
little while they give you a short robe
they don't actually make you wear it it
looks kind of stupid and that's to show
that you're a novice an undergraduate
they get and you're not to wear it it's
against the rules to wear it after you
get your degree these seniors are going
to keep these robes they're going to
keep them as a designation of their rank
they have joined the educated they are
not novices anymore the achievement that
they've made is of course chiefly theirs
each one because just try go home
tonight and do it they won't because
they're done with that for a while go
home and get some great book and sit
down and study it for three hours
it's an enormous test of the soul these
seniors have passed that test not once
and not twice but daily for a long time
that's what they've done and of course
it's their effort and their thinking and
therefore it's natural and right for
them to think that this is their day and
that is true
only in part because of course everybody
else I've named so far and for each one
of these seniors each of the other
seniors are essential elements of their
education the word college means
partnership and it will not work unless
we all work together and can rely upon
one another and we can hear and so at
the same time that they're extremely
grateful to their teachers and to
everyone here and to you who help make
all this possible they are also aware
that this has been an enormous effort to
them but I remind them and I remind all
of you it is not your effort alone
remember always all your life to be
grateful and we will remember to be
grateful to you there's a kind of a
scandal about the senior class they get
this is not the scandal they come to
senior dinner and these are very good
singers and violin players and cello
players and they make longer toasts that
a single senior class typically does
they're worthy Bunch
that's fun and interesting about them
they are by the numbers we have and the
numbers are no academic numbers you know
test scores and grade point average
there of course not the measure of a
quality of a person even of the
intellectual quality of a person but
these are the best qualified ever and I
think next year's might be better
but having said that they're just like
seniors in this they all think that the
freshmen and sophomores are nerds and
that the quality of the college is
falling off sharply and you know that's
the first time I ever heard anybody say
that except when it was said about them
here's the scandal Hillsdale College is
very unusual for a liberal arts college
it's possible it's unique it's rare
anyway we have the same number of boys
and girls next year's class looks like
it might have a few more boys and the
academic profile if you look at those
numbers I talked about for the boys and
the girls is exactly the same right and
on the other hand girls make better
grades than boys about a tenth of a
point on the average grade point average
and I'm about to ask the top ten to
stand up and you'll see what I'm talking
about
with the top 10 graduates please stand
up
the Anna Mikkel the valedictorian
biochemistry I'm sorry to report as a
4.0 we don't like that to happen around
here
the Delaney layman 3.96 or something
somebody gave her an a-minus and I'm
gonna give whoever that was a bonus and
they were all girls right and what does
that prove if you put those numbers
together with that fact I just showed
you it means that boys are just as smart
as girls they're just more often stupid
but in honor of the boys
I would like Jacob Weaver the 11th
student in the class to stand back
[Applause]
Jacob is going to University of Michigan
Law School right and I had him in class
when to use the first but I thought that
boy is just a dumb as heck yeah the
valedictorian in the salutatorian stand
up please so everybody can just look at
you two
we pick an outstanding senior man and
woman it's a rigorous process that
involves all the groups in the college
the interview it's hard it's a big vote
- I always vote for myself I never win
and there are always exceptional people
Dustin platen is going into a life
charitable service in hurry
Madison frame has gone to the University
of Michigan graduate school in
biochemistry and she too has high
charitable purposes and somebody told me
that they're engaged is that true
standout features
No
yeah you're all wondering what I'm
wondering if you look at Madison and you
look at Dustin why would she marry him I
don't know that's happened once before
Zach Howard married Elizabeth Peters
Betsy Peters had been 400 Peters kids
come here and Betsy is one of the
smartest girls I ever met in my life as
is Madison and you know Zach and Dustin
you know they're pretty clever I thank
the senior class officers we together
decided to invite the vice president and
of course that introduces lots of moving
parts and trouble for everybody in the
world and I told him that and I said
it'll be great but and you know they
there's a political article about this
morning and it said really delicious
because all the bad parts are false but
Dad
but isn't that I just decided this right
well I don't do it that way I can if I
if it weren't true that I could then
it'd be chaos right but I did it with
them and they're just a pain in the
toukas and so I would like senior class
president Rossi Lane and vice president
nor whine rate and secretary Loren itzel
and treasurer Casey Reeves and social
chair Claire Hughes and fundraising
chair Payton Bowen to stand up please
with the members of the senior class
stand up and please be recognized please
thank you
Razi lanes gonna give a speech later
it's senior class president I don't know
if it's gonna be good but I'm assured
it's gonna be short our commencement
speaker is a man of constant and urgent
business his are the affairs of war and
peace of a great nation in the world he
is the second executive in our
constitutional republic I think how far
that is from what we do here the time
and energy of our college are consumed
in things that happened long ago or ever
abide we have almost no courses on any
particular subject of public policy
people always think you know I myself
for example if I didn't go on the radio
pretty regularly I wouldn't read the
news at all it's not true but I read it
more than I would and I read it as much
as I have to we teach old stuff right
because we haven't commenced yet that's
happening today do you see how that
makes us vulnerable because you know we
don't really have any way to defend
ourselves we're not people of urgent
well I kind of am a person of urgent
affairs I have a lot of work to do and
I'm reasonably prudent man maybe but the
kind of thing that the Vice President
does people like that they have power
and you know tyrants when they have
power this is the first kind of thing
that they abolish because why we're not
learning here that the latest guy you
met with a crest on his shoulder or
something is God himself we're actually
learning about God himself and so
tyrants don't like that do you see why
it matters so much how they rule and in
a free republic
its glory is it it protects all the
rights including the highest rights that
are exercised here the vice-president is
obviously complicated to address our
body by the constitutional office that
he holds second in the land doesn't
matter whether you voted for him or not
if you love the constitutional republic
in the representative form that's
supposed to protect our liberties he's
doing that right now but is he I wonder
qualified by reputation and character
also qualified by his inner nature by
the thing that moves him to address us
here today my favorite thing among many
that I have heard him say he said on
this campus and it was printed in him
Primus first he quotes the story from
the calvin coolidge to show the nature
as calvin coolidge conceived of the
executive office Coolidge writes today I
became president my son the son died
soon after this he lost his son had just
started to work in a tobacco field and
one of his fellow laborers said to him
if my father was president I would not
work in a tobacco field and Young Calvin
Coolidge the junior said if my father
were your father you would
then the vice-president goes goes on to
save his own attitude to the young if
the president is speaking of the
presidency in this speech has the true
interest of the young at heart he will
not flatter them nor let hit them adore
him for in flattery is condescension and
in adoration is direction nor should it
be the president's business to presume
to direct them it is difficult enough to
do right by one's own children no one
can be the father of a whole countenance
youth to be successful statesmen have to
be assertive people to be great
they must bow before necessary things
like work and the care of their own
children and before elevated things like
learning and like God these later things
are quite beyond their power and they
must not resent but they must respect
and protect that Mike Pence is qualified
to be here today because he wrote those
things right there please welcome the
vice president United States
thank you
and thank you dr. Armond remarkable
welcome I need to remind myself to never
follow dr. Arnn
to a podium again he has become my
friend I I don't use the word mentor
loosely but president of Hillsdale
College has been a mentor to me dr. Arnn
under your leadership Hillsdale College
has risen to national prominence as
never before educating a generation to
carry freedom forward and these students
and this nation are in your debt would
you join me in showing your appreciation
for the 12th president of Hillsdale
College dr. Larry arm
before I get started let me make a
promise promise to all these students
unlike dr. Arnn I will not be asking you
to define the good to the Board of
Trustees to these distinguished members
of this remarkable faculty former
governor or congressman Walberg to all
our distinguished on a recent guest to
all the proud parents and all the family
and friends gathered here and most
importantly to the extraordinary men and
women seated before me today the class
of 2018 thank you for giving me the
honor of addressing this 166
commencement ceremony for this beacon of
Liberty and American ideals that is
Hillsdale College
and let me begin by bringing greetings
from a good friend of mine it was also a
great admirer of Hillsdale College he
asked me to pass along his
congratulations to the class of 2018 I
bring greetings and congratulations from
the 45th President of the United States
of America president Donald Trump
now Karen and I are really honored to be
back at this exceptional institution to
be a part of this commencement and we're
also humbled by the recognition that
will be bestowed on us today I mean
allow me to commend you dr. Arnn and the
faculty for having the especially good
judgement to honor my wife with an
honorary degree today I guarantee you
that if you were looking at the academic
averages in our family they would
reflect the academic achievement of the
top 11 graduates of this class my wife
is a career educator and author and
artist she's traveled across our home
state and across this country supporting
worthy causes benefitting vulnerable
children and our military families would
you all just join me in thanking the
second lady of the United States of
America Karen has where he or she is an
RCA
for my part I've always marveled at
Hillsdale College is long and often
lonely stand for freedom in America this
College was founded at a time of great
consequence in the life of our nation a
time when Americans were deeply divided
over the meaning and purpose of our
country and whether as the Declaration
of Independence forcefully states that
we are in fact all created equal but for
the founders of Hillsdale College the
truths of the American Founding were
just that true for all people at all
times in 1844 those men and women did
what no other college had done up to
that time Hillsdale College prohibited
any discrimination based on race
religion and gender at its very founding
they established this institution to
provide sound learning necessary to
preserve the principles and the promise
of America and so has Hillsdale done in
every era sense inscribed on central
hall I'm told are the words may earth be
better and heaven be Richard because of
the life and labor of Hillsdale College
and so it has been true but I also know
these words will continue to ring true
for generations to come because of the
men and women of the Hillsdale College
class of 2018 this is an extraordinary
group of men and women who have
accomplished extraordinary things in
their time here and they've only just
begun
366 strong representing 37 states in
five countries you've persevered through
all of the most challenging and
transformative education xeni where in
the country now it seems at times that
we live in an age of grim relativism but
here this class has seen the power of
unchanging truth to change lives you've
learned the character is destiny and
that it's essential to self-government
and that right conduct is its own reward
and it seems we we live in a time where
too many disregard that wisdom of the
past that dr. Arendt spoke about so
eloquently but here you've been grounded
in the traditions and teachings that are
our greatest inheritance in America and
the teachings and traditions that will
always be the surest foundation of a
boundless American future in a word your
education at Hillsdale has taught you
not what to do but what to be and today
you'll receive a diploma that's been
minted in Independence and tempered with
truth so for all you have done to reach
this moment class of 2018 give
yourselves a round of applause we're
proud of each and every one of you
but today is a day of celebration but
it's also a day of appreciation
especially I know I speak for this class
when I say it's especially true for
those who believed in you
and helped bring you to this day your
friends your professors and of course
your wonderful families I mean let's be
honest no one comes to a commencement to
hear the speaker in fact if you took
every commencement speaker this College
has ever had and laid them end and it'd
probably be a good thing but all of you
gathered here gathered around this
incredible class are here to revel in
the accomplishments represented by those
in the cap and gown but they know that
today is as much your accomplishment as
theirs so before we go one step further
class of 2018 would you mind just
standing up for a second turn around
catch the eye of your loved ones your
brothers sisters grandparents and
especially your impoverished parents and
just show them how much you appreciate
all they've done to bring you to this
day
[Applause]
thanks for that
today you the members of the class of
2018 will graduate from this
extraordinary college and enter new
careers and endeavors so before I go
further I'd like to take a moment to
talk about what good timing you have
you'll be glad to know the America that
awaits your energies and ambitions is
experiencing a new era of opportunity
and optimism
you're beginning your careers at a time
of growing American economy and restored
American stature at home and abroad and
I can personally attest from my travels
across this nation faith in America is
rising once again
on the world stage you've seen America
embracing our role as leader of the free
world with action just this week on Iran
North Korea and Monday America will lead
the world again when we open our new
embassy in Jerusalem the capital of
Israel
here at home businesses large and small
are growing again more than 3.1 million
new jobs in the last 15 months
unemployment is at a 17-year low and the
best news for all of you new graduates
is that there's more job openings in
America today than ever before in our
nation's history
and let me say it's no accident or
coincidence faith in America is rising
again because President Trump and our
entire administration have been
advancing the very principles that you
learned here in the halls at Hillsdale
College the principles that have always
been the source of America's greatness
and strength in this White House as the
president has said we fight for the West
with all our minds and our wills and our
souls as he said in Warsaw Poland we've
been expanding freedom cutting taxes
rolling back the regulatory state
returning authority to the people into
the States and we've been upholding the
Constitution of the United States and
defending all the god-given liberties
enshrined there including the
unalienable right to life
truth is when you leave this place
you're going to find an America filled
with promise being built again anew on a
foundation of personal responsibility
and individual freedom but I also
believe that faith in America is rising
again for one more reason for despite
the fact that we live in a time when
traditional values and even religious
convictions are increasingly
marginalized by a secular popular
culture a time when it's become
acceptable even fashionable to malign
religious belief in this time I believe
with all my heart that faith in America
is rising as well
now full disclosure people who know me
well know that I'm a Christian they're
conservative and a Republican in that
order as a good book says I'm not
ashamed of the gospel in fact it was 40
years ago this spring that I put my
faith in Christ as a freshman at another
liberal arts college not very far from
here and while in some places deeply
held religious belief is becoming more
rare leading some to claim that
America's rich faith tradition will soon
be a relic of our nation's past it just
isn't so facts are facts
faith is rising across America I see it
every day in communities large and small
in the way Americans respond in good
times and in great hardship the faith of
the American people shines for it I see
it as I travel across this great country
as countless Americans take the time to
tell us often with great emotion the
sweetest words we ever hear I'm praying
for you
and I know they mean it and I see it
right now right here at Hillsdale
College an institution founded by those
who proclaim themselves grateful to God
for His inestimable blessings even as
many continue to forecast the decline of
religion in American life the truth is
as President Trump recently said this is
a nation of faith and faith continues to
exert an extraordinary hold on the
hearts and minds of a growing number of
Americans in fact the percentage of
Americans who live out their religion on
a weekly basis praying going to church
reading and believing in the Bible has
remained remarkably consistent over the
decades even as the population of the
United States has grown by leaps and
bounds I mean think about it today
relative to the population four times as
many Americans go to church on a regular
basis than at the time of our nation's
founding religion in America isn't
receding it's just the opposite
faith is gaining new life across America
every day for my part I've long believed
that nothing is more important to the
future of this nation faith has always
been the wellspring of hope for millions
of Americans from our very founding
faith has been the foundation of our
freedom as well and religion was
recognized by our founders is essential
to the Republic it's a truth that's been
taught here at Hillsdale it would not be
a new thought for this class this is a
place where faith flourishes I I know
with admiration that Hillsdale will very
soon open your new Christ Chapel just a
few short months it'll be the largest
college chapel built in America in
almost 100 years
you know Hillsdale has always recognized
the wisdom beautifully expressed by our
nation's first vice president John Adams
who said and I quote our Constitution
was made only for a moral and religious
people and it is wholly inadequate for
the government of any other
as all of you can attest here at
Hillsdale students and professors of all
different faith traditions sharpen one
another just as iron sharpens iron as
you prepare to leave this special place
I just encourage you to take take your
convictions into every facet of your
life add your voices and your values to
this great American experiment class of
2018 at Hillsdale College you've
received an education uniquely grounded
in American ideals but as the Good Book
says to whom much is given much will be
required and so it is with each of you
your education in the liberal arts has
empowered you to conserve the
foundations of our freedom and you are
now uniquely suited and I believe you
are uniquely called to renew the fabric
of our national life with your character
and with your ideals make no mistake
about it this is an ongoing and
monumental task it's not for the faint
of heart or the small-minded it will
require courage and tenacity and
greatness of spirit at times you will
face opposition even ridicule for taking
a stand for what you know to be right
but as you've learned here at Hillsdale
strength rejoices in the challenge
and remember the most heroic acts and
the greatest feats aren't the stuff of
headlines and fame they're actually to
be found in the daily choices that
you'll make and the habits that you've
already begun to form ultimately whether
you become a part or the deeming and
renewing the time comes down to whether
you live what you've learned here at
Hillsdale College and so I urge you with
the greatest respect continue to grow as
men and women of character continue to
forge friendships that will help you
grow as a person and pursue what's right
form strong vibrant and loving families
the foundation of our free society where
you pass along our cherished values to
the next generation continue to build
strong communities those little platoons
that shape all who dwell within them and
in the process shape America itself and
never forget that timeless wisdom once
enshrined on that old sign on m99
Hillsdale it's the people
so thank you for the honor of addressing
you today and as I close let me
encourage you
Hillsdale class of 2018 have faith faith
in yourselves proven by what you've
accomplished to get you to this very day
faith in the principles and the ideals
that you learned here principles that
bind us together as a people and give
purpose to our nation faith that America
is rising and that you have a role to
play in redeeming the time and lastly I
pray that you'll also leave this place
with faith as Winston Churchill
reflected before our Congress that in
his words some great purpose and design
is being worked out here below of which
we have the honor to be faithful
servants and trust that he who brought
you this far will never leave you nor
forsake you he never will if you hold
fast to him if you live according to all
that you have learned and the examples
that you have seen in this special place
if you rededicate yourselves to the
noble mission that is always animated
the graduates of this conquer college I
just know the bottom of my heart right
after we get done making this nation
great again your generation will make
America greater than ever before so
congratulations
the class of 2018 you did it this day is
yours your future starts today god bless
you god bless Hillsdale College and god
bless
the United States of America
that beautiful speech was a direct
radiation from the fine character of
Mike Pence but I'm not sure Stephen Ford
should have told him some of that stuff
he told him where is Ford he's probably
hiding Karen pence is the second lady of
the United States of America she has
been the first lady of Indiana she has
to be yes degree and the MS degree from
Butler University she taught school for
25 years she has founded several
charities to help and guide the youth
along the paths that the vice president
just indicated she is an award-winning
artist especially for her illustrations
in a book a children's book by her
daughter Charlotte that my wife has been
looking at and says that it's just
gorgeous you should get it it's called
Marlon Bundy's a day in the life of the
vice-president she is the wife Mike
Pence since 1985 and she is the mother
of Michael Charlotte and Audrey
Mike Mike and Karen would you come
forward please
okay see waiting go
upon the recommendation of the Faculty
of Hillis Koch college and with the
authority vested in me by its Board of
Trustees I confer upon Karen su Pence
and Mike Pence the honorary degrees
doctor of public service
[Applause]
I just offered Karen pence a job at the
Hillsdale Academy the vice president
actually knows that we invited him to
get her here we have a new trustee from
a friend of several years now
he was raised in Slavic village in
Cleveland he's a member of the 1962
graduating class of Benedictine high
school he graduated from Cleveland State
with a bachelor's degree in an MBA from
the University of Virginia he went into
business he worked for the Ohio Sealy
company mattress company and became the
president of it so he was the boss and
then he writes that over philosophic
differences must have been some bigger
boss than he I guess he left them and
decided and decided to go into
competition with the biggest mattress
company in the world he founded the
original Mattress Factory in 1990 and it
has thrived he says it's because he just
had one principal I think that was the
philosophic difference he had always do
the right thing he's a TV personality
maybe not lately but he used to
advertise his mattresses on television
in Ohio and I've heard I tell people
that I know him now now I owe the
mattress guy they say he's a man of a
high principle I got the idea he might
join our Board of Trustees because of
the questions that he would ask me they
were smart house this house that he knew
how to read the financial statements of
the college and first time I offered him
to be on the board and the first time I
offered him an honorary degree he turned
me down flat both with the argument I
don't want anything won't take anything
well I prevailed but in the name of duty
you should do this I said cuz you know
you seniors should remember this if you
can do a good thing then you must not up
to you Patricia chose insky grew up in
the same neighborhood as her husband Ron
she graduated from Holy Name High School
she made Ron in 1966 she worked as a
clerk for a while for the Cuyahoga
County Probate Court and then she
started having children and after that
grandchildren she has six of those
children and some grandchildren 60 maybe
I don't know she takes care of them and
of her church and of her neighbors and
of her community she is the vice
president of the trees in ski foundation
and she is the president of the trees in
ski family Ron and Patricia will you
come forward please
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
be better for Karen pins to teach here
than at the University of Indiana would
[Applause]
[Laughter]
under the direction of James Holloman
the superb Hillsdale College Chamber
Choir
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
the skies
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you Jim the senior class president
is Razi Lane he comes from North
Carolina majors in politics and history
he's been on the student Federation a
few good men young America's for freedom
the College Republicans are a in his
dormitory that means we think he was a
leader he's going to the Notre Dame Law
School after graduation and he hopes
then to be a naval officer it's easy to
make fun of Rosie it's almost as easy to
make fun of Rosie as of Jacob Weaver but
I'm done with that now Rosie is one of
the most noble minded young men I know
Rosalind
Thank You vice president mrs. pence dr.
Arne Hillsdale College family thank you
for this opportunity to the class of
2018
I am honored to serve as your class
president your love and encouragement
means more to me than you can ever know
we seniors are proud to be joined by the
vice president of the United States and
the second lady Mike and Karen pence on
behalf of the Hillsdale College
graduating class of 2018 we are grateful
for their visit today
to our faculty we could not be more
thankful because of you we are inspired
to become the men and women of character
that God created us to be finally
graduating with us our four United
States Marine Corps officers Mitchell
moutarde Jean Pendergrass Charles Agee
in Santiago Quintana on behalf of the
class of 2018 we thank you for your
service
if you
although the world beyond our walls is
foreboding we have every reason to take
heart Hillsdale College classrooms have
a long and proud history of training men
and women who courageously rise to meet
the challenges of our world 420 of hills
dales forefathers enlisted in the Union
Army sergeant Moses Luce of the 4th
Michigan infantry demonstrated the
charger spirit when he charged through a
field of fire to save the life of a
fellow student and classmate Asher
Lafleur Lucis story typifies the
Hillsdale legacy and today fellow
graduates with great honor we adopt
their legacy as our own Hillsdale
College students are also proud to serve
their communities I recall when a few
good men crew redecorated miss Cheryl
Fox apartment last fall our project
brought tears of joy to her eyes these
moments define us both as a class and
his young men and women to graduate with
you for me is a high honor from students
to staff Hills Dells kindness shines
through one evening mr. John Mack a
security employee shared with me
something that I will never forget Russy
he said if I can live my whole life and
only touch one heart each day then son I
have lived a life worth living mr. max
wisdom is inspiring encourage everyone
you meet to be the best person that they
can be today commencement marks more for
us than a graduation we are called by
the high tradition of our predecessors
to bear the torch of truth in an ever
darkening world we are not promised an
easy future but our times call us to
excellence never to despair in the words
of Abigail Adams great necessities call
out great virtues when a mind is raised
and animated to seems that engage the
heart then those qualities which
otherwise lay dormant wake into life and
form the character of the hero and the
Statesman many will test our resolve
others will certainly to write us for it
may we remind them that we are men and
women of Hillsdale College we do not
surrender to the trials of life we
rejoice in their challenge
Psalm 39 teaches that the measure of our
days is unknown what would we do with
the blessings we've been given my prayer
is that we would live lives worthy of
the legacy that we today stands to
inherit for our truly great leaders are
the humble souls who through small acts
of sacrifice positively transform the
lives of others may we remember that our
time on earth is but brief it is
incumbent upon us to spend it well
joyfully extolling the good true and the
beautiful that we have here so come to
cherish may God bless each of your
futures and may he continue his blessing
upon the great and noble work of
Hillsdale College thank you
[Applause]
guess that was great I'm glad I didn't
make fun of him Hillsdale College is
governed by the best support of Trustees
I ever saw and I would ask its members
to stand up and be recognized please
cleaves dump has got a kid Dugan who's
about to walk across this stage and
Dugan will be the third of the depth I
bet the girls are here and there are 19
large children still to come well the
candidates for doctoral degrees please
stand there the first upon the
recommendation of the Faculty of
Hillsdale College and with the authority
vested in me by its Board of Trustees I
confer upon each of you the degree for
which you have been a candidate and
admit you to all the rights privileges
and responsibilities to which you are
entitled and obliged thank you
dr. estrine oh well the doctor of
philosophy graduates in politics please
come forward
Nathan Gill
Kathleen Claire Thompson
[Applause]
Nathan and Kathleen are the first to
receive an earned doctorate from
Hillsdale College and its 174 year
history please join me in congratulating
well the candidates for master's degrees
please stand
meow Stevie upon the recommendation of
the Faculty of Hillsdale College and
with the authority vested in me by its
Board of Trustees I confer upon each of
you the degree for which you have been a
candidate and admit you to all the
rights privileges and responsibilities
to which you are entitled and obliged
dr. post Rita will the Master of Arts
graduates and politics please come
forward
johnathan case
[Applause]
William John Casey
[Applause]
Maureen Collins
[Applause]
[Music]
Stephen Miceli Ghana prowl
[Applause]
Brandon Curtis headlock
[Applause]
an ELISA
Katherine Lee
[Applause]
Stevie Nicole Nichols
[Applause]
Sarah Jane Anton
[Applause]
Zachery de Jean Rogers
[Applause]
kcj Wheatland
[Applause]
congratulations to all of our masters
graduates
dr. Arnn the awarding of graduate
degrees is complete well the hill so
cogs class of 2018 please stand
[Applause]
[Music]
upon the recommendation of the Faculty
of Hillsdale College and with the
authority vested in me by its Board of
Trustees I confer upon each of you the
degree for which you've been a candidate
and admit you to all the rights
privileges and responsibilities to which
you are entitled and obliged
congratulations
be seated well the candidates in
accounting please come forward
Adam Allen Steph arcus Bachelor of Arts
accounting
[Applause]
David Stedman Lowry Bachelor of Science
accounting departmental honors
accounting
[Applause]
amanda marie regal Bachelor of Arts
accounting magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors accounting summer hope Burkholder
Bachelor of Arts accounting magna [ __ ]
laude a departmental honors accounting
Christian Marie
well Meyer Bachelor of Arts accounting
magna [ __ ] laude a departmental honors
accounting David Preston Stone a
Bachelor of Arts accounting magna [ __ ]
laude accounting departmental honors
accounting Samantha Jane Howard Bachelor
of Science accounting
Pilar Patricia furlong Bachelor of Arts
accounting Logan Derek Kauffman Bachelor
of Arts accounting Laura Blair Sanderson
a Bachelor of Arts American Studies
departmental honors American Studies
[Applause]
Hannah
Elizabeth Watts Bachelor of Arts
American Studies magna [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors American Studies
cassadee Carol sift astad Bachelor of
Arts American Studies magna [ __ ] laude
michael christopher Lucchese Bachelor of
Arts American Studies [ __ ] laude
departmental honors American Studies
John Robert gage Bachelor of Arts
American Studies [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
well the candidates in art please come
forward
Madeleine Rachel greep the Bachelor of
Arts art Latin and mathematics summa [ __ ]
laude Elsa Karen lager quest Bachelor of
Arts English and art magna [ __ ] laude
elise Marie Klein's a Bachelor of Arts
art and Spanish magna [ __ ] laude
Isaac Nehemiah del a Bachelor of Arts
art departmental honors art Anna
Elizabeth Emma Titus Bachelor of Arts
American Studies and art summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors American Studies
Emily Marie Rinaldi bachelor of science
art magna [ __ ] laude rachel lynn Reynolds
Bachelor of Arts arts departmental
honors art Patrick robear's Lucas
Bachelor of Arts art in English
summer Maurice Smith Bachelor of Arts
English and art magna [ __ ] laude
stephanie Andros Bachelor of Arts art
well the candidates in biochemistry
please come forward
Casey Paul Schuylkill Bachelor of
Science biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors biochemistry trade
Dewayne Van Aken Bachelor of Science
biochemistry [ __ ] laude departmental
honors biochemistry James Irvin Friedel
the third Bachelor of Science
biochemistry [ __ ] laude
Luke Patrick Miller Bachelor of Science
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors biochemistry Emma
Caracalla Bachelor of Science
biochemistry [ __ ] laude
Andrea Jasmine Lee Bachelor of Science
biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors biochemistry lauren
ashley barlas Bachelor of Science
biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors biochemistry
[Applause]
Madeleine Victoria Jepsen Bachelor of
Arts biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude an
affair Mathis Bachelor of Science
biochemistry [ __ ] laude
Sara Edwin Benson Bachelor of Science
biochemistry [ __ ] laude taylor michelle
Hanul Bachelor of Science biochemistry
Emily classmen era Bachelor of Science
biochemistry [ __ ] laude the Lynn Kate
quinone especially of science
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors biochemistry Anna
Susan Nicole Bachelor of Arts
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors biochemistry
valedictorian
Madison Lynn frame Bachelor of Science
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors biochemistry Kaitlin
Renee Burke ah Bachelor of Science
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors biochemistry gabriel
mark Joseph pre our Bachelor of Science
biochemistry [ __ ] laude a departmental
honors biochemistry Brenna Anita shrimp
Bachelor of Arts biology Luiza Sophia
was a loose key bachelor of science
biology Lauren grace Miller bachelor of
science biology Emma Virginia Carville
bachelor of science biology
Lydia Joyce see Paul bachelors science
biology [ __ ] laude Jonathan David couch
junior bachelor of science biology [ __ ]
laude
Douglas Leon Phillips bachelor of
science biology Taylor Murray Zimmer
bachelor of science biology [ __ ] laude
stephen daniel sore about science
biology magna [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Abigail Naomi angel bachelor of science
biology summa [ __ ] laude a departmental
honors biology Brandi Lee block bachelor
science biology [ __ ] laude departmental
honors biology andrea
lynn wallace bachelor of science biology
magna [ __ ] laude julia katherine hooter
bachelor of science biology magna [ __ ]
laude
Michaela marie miller bachelor of
science biology departmental honors
biology kelsey Francis Scott Minh
bachelor science biology summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors biology Mona Co one
Giroux Bachelor of Arts biology [ __ ]
laude benjamin peter winger bachelor of
arts biology [ __ ] laude
Alexis Theresa Ziegler Bachelor of
Science biology
[Applause]
well the candidates in chemistry please
come forward Sara Elizabeth Kilgore
bachelor of science chemistry [ __ ] laude
Jacob Edward Ross bachelor science
chemistry [ __ ] laude departmental honors
chemistry Stephen Kristoff new spatula
science chemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors chemistry Devin
Patrice award bachelor science chemistry
and Applied Mathematics Delaney nicole
layman bachelor science chemistry summa
[ __ ] laude departmental honors chemistry
salutatorian mica Wesley Heinz bachelor
science chemistry and music summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors chemistry
departmental honors music Jacob William
Hann Bachelor of Arts chemistry [ __ ]
laude zachary Andrew van orman bachelor
of science chemistry [ __ ] laude
Douglas Randall Wyman Bachelor of
Science chemistry
well the candidates and Christian
Studies please come forward
faith Rebecca leaving Bachelor of Arts
Christian studies Victoria hope Whitman
Bachelor of Science Christian studies
Danielle hope Rudess Wailea Bachelor of
Arts Christian Studies well the
candidates in Classical Studies please
come forward Megan Nicole Hazleton
Bachelor of Arts lachen summa [ __ ] laude
emily ann Barnum Bachelor of Arts a
Greek magna [ __ ] laude a departmental
honors a Greek Shia Milton Whitmore
Bachelor of Arts Greek magna [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors Greek John Robert
Lemire James Bachelor of Arts Classical
Studies summa [ __ ] laude Sam Jay Phillips
Bachelor of Arts Classical Studies Marie
Anastasia Hill a Bachelor of Arts
classical studies of magna [ __ ] laude
Brian Christopher Hall Bachelor of Arts
Latin magna [ __ ] laude a departmental
honors Latin
Michael Jerome Howard Bachelor of Arts
lutein [ __ ] laude
Mark Martin Chapman it's Harrison
Bachelor of Arts Classical Studies and
history Tara Nicole um Bachelor of Arts
politics and Latin summa [ __ ] laude the
candidates economics please come forward
Jordan Lee Heights bachelor of science
economics and mathematics magna [ __ ]
laude a departmental honors economics
Ian Despres Bachelor of Science
economics
John Dugan Delp Bachelor of Arts
economics and Spanish mega [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors economics grace
Elizabeth Schroder Bachelor of Arts
economics Alexa Lee Tipton Bachelor of
Arts economics magna [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors economics cecilia
marie ballets Bachelor of Arts economics
and French [ __ ] laude a departmental
honors economics Adrian Rose carrier
Bachelor of Arts politics and economics
summa [ __ ] laude a departmental honors
economics Rachel Katherine Bear Bachelor
of Arts economics and politics summa [ __ ]
laude a departmental honors economics
Chloe Vanessa Algren Bachelor of Arts
economics [ __ ] laude departmental honors
economics Evan Michael Tandy bachelor
science applied mathematics and
economics departmental honors economics
Nathan David Jones Bachelor of Science
applied mathematics and economics
departmental honors economics Madalena
Marina Musa Reed Bachelor of Science
economics magna [ __ ] laude a departmental
honors economics Cassidy Maurice blonde
bachelor of science economics magna [ __ ]
laude a departmental honors economics
Claudia Meredith sladek Bachelor of Arts
economics magna [ __ ] laude
mark Andrew Englert Bachelor of Arts
economics Michelle Allison bara Bachelor
of Arts economics [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors economics
mkhaya Noel Rogers Bachelor of Science
economics Zachary would Pistorius
Bachelor of Arts economics Stephen
Michael Bennett Bachelor of Arts
economics summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors economics Jake Anthony Kenyon
Bachelor of Arts economics Lucas
McKinley bladder Bachelor of Arts
economics [ __ ] laude departmental honors
economics Alexandra K Howell bachelor of
science economics and mathematics magna
[ __ ] laude a departmental honors
economics scott mcclellan ba economics
Katherine Emily right Bachelor of Arts
economics [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Nathan Daniel Halloran Bachelor of Arts
economics magna [ __ ] laude
Charles Thomas aji Bachelor of Science
biochemistry and economics
anamarie de la pena summers bachelor of
science economics Tyler J Krieger
Bachelor of Arts economics Jackson Levi
bargain quest Bachelor of Arts economics
[ __ ] laude departmental honors economics
[Applause]
Peter Michael O'Rourke Bachelor of Arts
economics david ryan whitson a Bachelor
of Arts economics
Brendon Samuel noble bachelor of arts
economics [ __ ] laude departmental honors
economics Steve Sturken Berg Bachelor of
Arts economics Gregory mark Harrison
Bachelor of Arts economics summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors economics
[Music]
Casey Nicole Reeves Bachelor of Arts
Spanish and economics summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors economics Santiago
hatack Quintero Bachelor of Arts
economics Thomas Carl Ganz Bachelor of
Arts economics magna [ __ ] laude
Sergey Bostick bachelor science
economics George Teixeira and Sadie
bachelor science economics David Adams
Wortman bachelor of science economics
and applied mathematics magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors economics Tanner
Orion right bachelor of science
economics and applied mathematics magna
[ __ ] laude
[Applause]
well the candidates in English please
come forward
Daniel Robert Cody Bachelor of Arts
English magna [ __ ] laude
Brendan Richard Clary Blecher of English
Bachelor of Arts English cool laude erin
Bayless Andrews Bachelor of Arts English
magna [ __ ] laude
Ellen Murray sweet Bachelor of Arts
English summa [ __ ] laude
Heather Nicole Woodhouse Bachelor of
Arts English [ __ ] laude
Jacob Andrew Khun rot Bachelor of Arts
English
Matthew Jacob Wiley Bachelor of Arts
English Sarah Angela Das Gupta Bachelor
of Arts English
kiona Samina Shabazz Bachelor of Arts
English Hannah Christine Niemeyer
Bachelor of Arts English summa [ __ ] laude
Madison Lee Moore Bachelor of Arts
English magna [ __ ] laude megan elizabeth
perks Bachelor of Arts English summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors English
Rachel caddis Watson Bachelor of Arts
English magna [ __ ] laude
Brendan Andrew Ammerman Bachelor of Arts
English magna [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Holle Magdalena Omer bachelor of science
English [ __ ] laude katherine june
davenport Bachelor of Arts English and
art summa [ __ ] laude stephen Donald Sava
Bachelor of Arts English [ __ ] laude
rebecca Alison Willis Bachelor of Arts
English [ __ ] laude jennifer Lynn Malcolm
Bachelor of Arts English [ __ ] laude emily
alice bladder Bachelor of Arts history
and English [ __ ] laude alison Ruth
dexhart Bachelor of Arts English summa
[ __ ] laude kylie Victoria deal Bachelor
of Arts English magna [ __ ] laude and
[Applause]
Theresa Hotz Bachelor of Arts English
[ __ ] laude sarah christine Borja Bachelor
of Arts English and Spanish [ __ ] laude
Laura Catherine Forsythe Bachelor of
Arts English magna [ __ ] laude Chandler
David ride a Bachelor of Arts English
Theresa Marie Smith Bachelor of Arts
English Rebecca Lynn Reed Bachelor of
Arts English
Bridget Christine Hall Bachelor of Arts
English magna [ __ ] laude
Anastasia Ruth rogério Bachelor of Arts
English magna [ __ ] laude Elsa Christine
Epling Bachelor of Arts English
[Applause]
Samuel Michael Potter Bachelor of Arts
English
[Applause]
Dustin ray platon Bachelor of Arts
English summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors English well the candidates and
exercise science please come forward
Jordan Anthony halliburton Bachelor of
Science exercise science Eric Joseph
Coggan Bachelor of Science Exercise
Science [ __ ] laude Spencer
Owen nails Bachelor of Science Exercise
Science [ __ ] laude John Robert Lawrence
Terry Bachelor of Science Exercise
Science Lane Andrew White Bachelor of
Science exercise science
hey Leland Lawrence Bachelor of Science
exercise science summa [ __ ] laude laura
catherine Williamson Bachelor of Science
exercise science Lindy Jane wonders
Bachelor of Science exercise science
Nicholas Ryan try marry Bachelor of
Science exercise science well the
candidates in a financial management
please come forward Ryan at Gregory
butto Ski Bachelor of Arts financial
management - [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Austin Howard Adams Bachelor of Arts
financial management
Allison Linda Tamara Bachelor of Arts
financial management Oh a Sandra Rose
Leonard Bachelor of Science financial
management and applied mathematics [ __ ]
laude departmental Ono's financial
management Denton Lee Williams Bachelor
of Arts financial management
Timothy J Mills Bachelor of Arts
Financial Management Maxwell Henry
Pfeiffer Bachelor of Arts Financial
Management
Andrew Carl Wilcox Bachelor of Arts
Financial Management Nicholas Daniel
Chappell Bachelor of Science Financial
Management
Joseph Anthony Torres the third Bachelor
of Science financial management - pipe
mill owners financial management
John Joseph Burke Bachelor of Science
financial management [ __ ] laude
departmental honors financial management
droopy whiskey Bachelor of Science
financial management and mathematics
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors
financial management Christopher Lee
Jacobson Bachelor of Arts financial
management John dotty Kearney Bachelor
of Arts financial management alison
Katherine Arthur Bachelor of Arts
economics and financial management [ __ ]
laude departmental honors economics
Charlotte Amelia McFadden Bachelor of
Arts Financial Management summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors financial
management
Christina Lauren middle stets Bachelor
of Arts financial management anime IDI
Bachelor of Arts financial management
summa [ __ ] laude departmental honors
financial management
[Applause]
Seth William over la Bachelor of Arts
financial management Paul Matthew
Galloway Bachelor of Arts financial
management [ __ ] laude departmental honors
financial management Matthew James Hall
Bachelor of Arts financial management
[ __ ] laude
Maxwell Hayden Smith Bachelor of Arts
financial management departmental honors
financial management Johnathan Park
Andersen Bachelor of Arts financial
management departmental honors financial
management Luke John ends Bachelor of
Arts financial management school not a
departmental honors financial management
Peter Joseph Flynn Bachelor of Arts
financial management magna [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors financial management
Josh Joseph R Lasky Bachelor of Arts
financial management mark Nicholas
bewdley Bachelor of Arts financial
management [ __ ] laude departmental honors
financial management well the candidates
in French please come forward mark
Joseph NIDA Bachelor of Arts English and
French cool out a Catherine Jane shy
Bachelor of Arts French magna [ __ ] laude
Joanna Beth croaker Bachelor of Arts
French summa [ __ ] laude a departmental
honors of French
[Applause]
Therese Catherine Burgess Bachelor of
Arts French Madeleine Elizabeth Fry
Bachelor of Arts French magna [ __ ] laude
a departmental honors French Elizabeth
Amy Garner Bachelor of Arts French -
summa [ __ ] laude a departmental honors
French well the candidates in German
please come forward
Aaron August shilling Bachelor of Arts
English and German
[Music]
[Applause]
emilienne Dahlberg bachelor of science
history and german kz logan Baus
Bachelor of Arts German Paul Edward
Kenan Bachelor of Arts German Suman coup
summa [ __ ] laude
Joanna Rose Westerhof Bachelor of Arts
German magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors German Billy and Renee Martin
Bachelor of Arts German [ __ ] laude
departmental honors German Rachel
Lourdes Smith Bachelor of Arts exercise
science and German [ __ ] laude
departmental honors German William
Hunter Crockett Bachelor of Arts
political economy and German Carl
Matthias Berg Bachelor of Arts history
and German magna [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors history well the
candidates in Greek please come forward
Kenneth's in history please come forward
Jacob Reynolds Weaver Bachelor of Arts
history to pursue Macomb laude a
departmental honors history
Joshua Bryant Brooks Bachelor of Arts
history
Joshua Michael Schmid bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude Jacob Paul
Edward Peterson Bachelor of Arts history
[Applause]
Ethan Luke Williams Bachelor of Arts
History [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Kevin koishi Wilkinson Bachelor of Arts
history
Bryce Williams Snider bachelor of arts
history Keirsey Kathleen EB bachelor of
arts history [ __ ] laude
Jessica M Schuler a Bachelor of Arts
history
[Applause]
Zachary David Stone a Bachelor of Arts
history Reuben Levi Blake Bachelor of
Arts history Christopher Leighton Reilly
Bachelor of Arts history magna [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Nathaniel Shay Trainor bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude a departmental
honors history Erin Ava wonders bachelor
of arts history [ __ ] laude Sarah grace
troubiing bachelor of arts history [ __ ]
laude
Madeline Claire Adama lacus Bachelor of
Arts history and politics summa [ __ ]
laude Dean Reed Sinclair Bachelor of
Arts history
grace Victoria Moran Bachelor of Arts
history and art ralston Danielle Tucker
Bachelor of Arts history
ginamarie Harris at bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude
Stacey Eden eager Bachelor of Arts
history
magna [ __ ] laude and Bernadette Peterson
Bachelor of Arts history pans Frederick
noise bachelor science history [ __ ] laude
elizabeth Cameron Turner Bachelor of
Arts history Chandler Michelle lash
Bachelor of Arts history
[Applause]
Glynnis Rogelio Bachelor of Arts history
and theatre [ __ ] laude Mary Teresa daro
bachelor of arts history [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Finnegan Patrick Cleary bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] laude Sarah Mackenzie
Roddick bachelor of arts history magna
[ __ ] laude kyle Stanley eldritch Bachelor
of Arts history and political economy
[ __ ] laude departmental honors economics
Shawn Michaels Speer Bachelor of Arts
history Ian James McCrae Bachelor of
Arts history and politics departmental
honors history for the candidates in
International Studies and business
please come forward
McKenzie Nicole Yosi Bachelor of Arts
International Studies in business and
foreign language well the candidates in
Latin please come forward well the
candidates in marketing and management
please come forward
Matthew C Shran Bachelor of Arts
marketing and management [ __ ] laude Jacob
Lawrence ball Bachelor of Arts marketing
management magna [ __ ] laude william scott
jones Bachelor of Arts marketing
management
Kyle Jacob Marsh Bachelor of Arts
marketing management Daniel Peter
Drummond Bachelor of Arts marketing
management history magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors marketing management
Britney Alexandra man Bachelor of Arts
marketing management Ashley Lynn Moran
Bachelor of Arts marketing management
[Applause]
Kayla Maurice Tetzel bachelor of arts
marketing management magna [ __ ] laude
part mental honors marketing management
Hannah Francis squabbits Bachelor of
Arts marketing management KY Thomas
Quebec Bachelor of Arts marketing
management Joseph Raymond Peppa Peppa
lardo a Bachelor of Arts marketing
management
Joshua Scott Lee browser Bachelor of
Arts marketing management bo Charles
Jarrett Bachelor of Arts marketing
management
well the candidates in mathematics and
Applied Mathematics please come forward
: James Saunders Bachelor of Science
applied mathematics jean-marie
Pendergrass bachelor science mathematics
[ __ ] laude
Duncan gray Voyles bachelor of science
economics and makam at mathematics magna
[ __ ] laude a departmental honors
economics gary daniel Dunkerley bachelor
of science mathematics and English
[Applause]
Trustin john rogers bachelor science
mathematics [ __ ] laude a departmental
honors mathematics Ryan Joseph Asher
Bachelor of Arts mathematics
[Applause]
Aiden Michael [ __ ] bachelor science
accounting and mathematics departmental
honors accounting Daniel topic bachelor
of science mathematics kirk david
williams bachelor of science mathematics
and economics departmental honors
mathematics well the candidates and
music please come forward
Brendan Matthew King Bachelor of Arts
music magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors music Jonathan David Hendrickson
Bachelor of Arts music
Scecina Elizabeth Finnegan Bachelor of
Arts music Sarah Colleen shooty Bachelor
of Arts music magna [ __ ] laude Quintin
Stewart Herrmann Bachelor of Arts music
well the candidates in philosophy please
come forward
Samuel Douglas Adamson Bachelor of Arts
English and Philosophy magna [ __ ] laude
Andrew John Kern Bachelor of Arts
philosophy caleb michael harmon bachelor
science philosophy well the candidates
in philosophy and religion please come
forward
Nathan Stephen Steinmeier bachelor of
science philosophy and religion
[Applause]
Hannah Christine McIntyre Bachelor of
Arts philosophy and religion magna [ __ ]
laude I Millea Christine Hansen Bachelor
of Arts philosophy and religion well the
candidates in physics please come
forward
Rebecca Kay round a Bachelor of Science
physics and music [ __ ] laude well a
candidates in political economy please
come forward the Noah
Knutson Jostens Bachelor of Arts
political economy Combe laude
Abraham Paul orth
Bachelor of Arts political economy
Charles Scott Panola Bachelor of Arts
political economy
Anthony James windall Bachelor of Arts
political economy Brandon William by
sher Bachelor of Arts political economy
Jonathan Daniel Moy Bachelor of Arts
political economy
[Applause]
while the candidates in politics please
come forward
Nathaniel Robert leamon bachelor of arts
politics magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors politics lianna J Pierce Bachelor
of Arts English in politics [ __ ] laude
brianna christine noble bachelor of arts
politics summa [ __ ] laude Kara on Schmidt
Bachelor of Arts politics
summa [ __ ] laude Christopher Dean Jones
Bachelor of Arts politics and religion
magna [ __ ] laude Noah McDonald Weinrich
Bachelor of Arts politics
magna [ __ ] laude Claire Elise Hughes
Bachelor of Arts politics in French
magna [ __ ] laude
Morgan Elizabeth brownfield a Bachelor
of Arts politics magna [ __ ] laude joshua
James Palladino Bachelor of Arts
politics and economics magna [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors economics English
Elizabeth Holcomb Hinton Bachelor of
Arts politics
magna [ __ ] laude Maisie Lane Mount
Bachelor of Arts politics summa [ __ ]
laude a departmental honors politics
[Applause]
Chiana
Nicole Eden Bachelor of Arts politics
summa [ __ ] laude Brandt Christoph
Christopher Foyle Cohen Bachelor of Arts
politics
Sloan Alexander McDonough Bachelor of
Arts politics
[Applause]
William Joshua Lee Bachelor of Arts
politics
[Applause]
Andrew Christopher Lange raised Bachelor
of Arts politics
Joshua Dean / gawky Bachelor of Science
politics
magna [ __ ] laude Razi Siddiqui Lane
Bachelor of Arts politics and history
magna [ __ ] laude
[Applause]
Kalista Lily ring Bachelor of Arts
politics in French summa [ __ ] laude
Payton Emma Bowen Bachelor of Arts
politics
[Applause]
Victoria Jean Watson Bachelor of Arts
politics
[ __ ] laude Madeleine and Conover Bachelor
of Arts politics in Spanish [ __ ] laude
Lindsey Elise vice Bachelor of Arts
politics
[Applause]
grace Murray Vandergriff Bachelor of
Arts politics
[Applause]
zowie Rose horns Bachelor of Arts
politics
Jackson Giovanni Ventrella Bachelor of
Arts politics
Geoffrey cannon Freiburg bachelor of
arts politics [ __ ] laude Mitchell Scott
moutarde bachelor of arts politics [ __ ]
laude
James Edward Reed Bachelor of Arts
politics
[ __ ] laude well the candidates in
psychology please come forward
Janina grace imperial bachelor of
science psychology magna [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors psychology
Mary Frances blender men bachelor
science psychology summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors psychology Abraham
Maroma cygwin Norman Bachelor of Arts
psychology Matthew Allen Coleman
bachelor science psychology [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors a psychology Colby
Kevin Clark Bachelor of Arts psychology
[ __ ] laude a departmental honors
psychology Hannah Katherine Brewer
bachelor of science psychology summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors psychology
[Applause]
Michaela
moniece overton bachelor science
psychology summa [ __ ] laude a
departmental honors psychology Morgan
Connie Blair bachelor of science
psychology jessica rake up Meyer
Bachelor of Arts psychology summa [ __ ]
laude a departmental honors psychology
[Applause]
Alise Francis Hutchinson Bachelor of
Arts psychology and art magna [ __ ] laude
a departmental honors psychology Elena
Loraine rumlow Bachelor of Science
psychology and political economy [ __ ]
laude a departmental honors psychology
and political economy Marie Elizabeth
Tyson Bachelor of Arts psychology and
English [ __ ] laude departmental honors
psychology
well the candidates and religion please
come forward
Matthew Austin Kendrick Bachelor of Arts
religion [ __ ] laude two more Jamil Khan
Bachelor of Arts religion at magna [ __ ]
laude
[Applause]
Andrea Nicole Beaudry Bachelor of Arts
religion well the candidates in rhetoric
and public address please come forward
megan marie kane Bachelor of Arts
rhetoric and public address [ __ ] laude
Alexandra Gabriella Nick rich Bachelor
of Arts rhetoric and public address
[Applause]
Fiona
Brennan Shea Bachelor of Arts rhetoric
and public address will the candidates
in Spanish please come forward
Emily Clara Joan bolivars Spanish
[Applause]
Jessica degree Bachelor of Arts English
and Spanish
John Sheeran Duffy Bachelor of Arts
Applied Mathematics and Spanish Katrina
Elizabeth mercero Bachelor of Arts
Spanish and politics magna [ __ ] laude
Maria Claire grin especially science
Spanish summa [ __ ] laude
Laurel Elizabeth that's all Bachelor of
Arts Spanish and English magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors Spanish Alexis
Victoria Pierce Bachelor of Arts Spanish
[ __ ] laude well the candidates in
sociology and social thought please come
forward Sport Management theatre please
come forward there we go
third time's the charm Brooke Lynn
Benson Bachelor of Arts history and
theater [ __ ] laude Ellen I'm a recreated
Bachelor of Arts Theater and English [ __ ]
laude a departmental auteurs theatre
[Applause]
nikolai alexander dignity bachelor of
arts history and theatre if there are
any other candidates who have not yet
come forward you may do so now
it's my honor on behalf of the Board of
Trustees to congratulate you on your
years of hard work an accomplishment
here and of course on your graduation
today if I go back some four and a half
years I salute you and your parents on
your selection of Hillsdale College I'll
admit to a bit of bias but I truly
believe you could have not you could not
have made a better choice you might have
received an education or pardon me I
don't think you made your choice
predicated on hills dales widely-held
reputation for beautiful year-round
weather
my sense is instead you made your
decision
based on the school's reputation and the
school's faculty you might have received
an education the quality of which would
roughly equal that which you have
received here that from but a handful of
other schools across the country from
the providential dr. Arnn through the
not to be equaled faculty through the
incredible administrators and the superb
support staff you have in my estimation
received a degree from a college that
has but one major fault
it is unique lost my train of thought
with apologies of
as you as you go forward I apologize my
memorization skills are not what they
were
[Music]
as you go forward remember the classes
you have had here the professor's you
have had they have no equal and remember
that you have a special obligation in
that very few of your peers about the
country share the knowledge that you
possess use that knowledge well use it
wisely use it daily again on behalf of
the Board of Trustees our warmest
congratulations to each and every one of
you as you go through life do not lose
touch with this important place Godspeed
[Applause]
Thank You chairman brought back please
stand for the alma mater led by the hill
so college chamber
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
please remain standing for the
benediction I invite the men to please
take off their caps may God the Father
who brought again from the dead our Lord
Jesus Christ the great Shepherd of the
Sheep preserve and sustain you may God
the Son who trampled down death by death
securing for us new life as the first
fruits of the new creation save and
guide you may God the Holy Spirit who
gives us the resurrection of life of
Jesus that we may call his father our
own equipments strengthen you for every
good work and the blessing of God
Almighty the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit Holy Trinity ever one be upon you
and remain with you always
amen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]